Il faut que j’écrive
un truc
vraiment original !
T’a pas une idée toi,
Haristote ?
Un bon café,
c’est ça le secret de la créativité,
parce que…
C’est pour ça
que le café booste la créativité.
Ce matin,
je sais pas ce qui se passe,
j’ai vraiment pas l’inspiration…
Bon,
j’en ai marre ;
je vais juste pomper Aristote
- non pas toi,
le philosophe,
celui sans H.
Après tout,
1000 idées de culture générale,
c’est pas fait
pour se prendre la tête !
C’est quoi,
le secret de la créativité ?
Comment se fait-il
que MOI
je sois réduit
à plagier Aristote
- non pas toi,
le philosophe,
celui sans H -
alors que d’autres
ont des idées géniales ?
Pour le savoir,
j’ai lu récemment
Voler comme un artiste
- en anglais Steal like an artist -
de l’essayiste américain Austin Kleon.
Comme d’habitude,
je vous permets de télécharger
mes notes de lecture,
en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou sur celui qui est dans la description,
puis en me laissant votre adresse e-mail.
Alors,
cet ouvrage,
c’est un petit livre
avec des dessins
et beaucoup de citations
- même sur Kindle -
et ce petit livre prétend révéler
« les dix secrets bien gardés
sur la créativité ».
Génial !
Tu te rends compte Haristote :
finies les heures
passées à brasser du vent !
finies les overdoses de caféine !
fini l’éternel plagiat d’Aristote
- pas toi,
le philosophe,
celui sans H -
Bon bah,
c’est parti :
voyons voir les dix secrets
de la créativité artistique.
Ça c’est quelque chose :
en réalité,
je suis déjà créatif !
Austin Kleon cite le théologien William Inge
:
« Qu'est-ce que l'originalité ?
Un plagiat non détecté.
»
Qu’est-ce que j’étais naïf :
moi je croyais les poètes grecs,
quand ils disent
que leur inspiration
leur vient des dieux.
Je connaissais pourtant la phrase de Picasso
:
« Les bons artistes copient,
les grands artistes volent »
- mais de là à en faire le premier secret
de la créativité !
Fondamentalement,
pour Austin Kleon,
on s’inspire toujours de quelqu’un,
alors autant le faire consciemment.
Et du coup,
ça donne un nouveau regard sur le monde :
l’artiste qui assume
la dimension mimétique de son inspiration
ne voit plus le bien
et le mal
- il voit des choses dignes d’être volées,
et d’autres
qui ne le sont pas.
La créativité,
ça demande donc d’être très pragmatique
:
« D'abord, tu trouves
ce qui vaut la peine d'être volé,
écrit Austin Kleon,
puis tu passes à autre chose.
C'est à peu près
tout ce qu'il y a à faire ».
Ce premier secret repose sur le fait
que la nature humaine
est fondamentalement mimétique.
Toute idée que peut avoir l’artiste,
quelqu’un l’a déjà eue,
sous une forme
ou une autre
- toute idée a donc
une GÉNÉALOGIE,
et l’enjeu de l’artiste débutant,
c’est de remonter l’arbre généalogique
lorsqu’il étudie ses modèles.
Pour ça,
il doit être très curieux,
lire beaucoup,
et prendre un maximum de notes,
afin de garder le fruit de ses vols
pour plus tard.
Austin Kleon a lui
ce qu’il appelle un « fichier morgue »
où il conserve toutes les idées
auxquelles il voudra donner vie
dans le futur.
Vous l’avez compris,
c’est ce premier secret
qui a donné son titre au livre.
Je peux rester des heures à mon bureau,
me préparer quinze cafés,
l’originalité authentique
n’existe pas ;
la clé de la créativité,
ce serait donc d’assumer
et de cultiver ses influences.
Donc c’est bon,
je peux continuer à plagier Aristote
- pas toi,
le philosophe,
celui sans H -
Mais en même temps…
c’est pas moi…
c’est…
…c’est le philosophe
qu’il ne faut pas nommer.
Austin Kleon me dirait :
« C’est pas toi,
POUR L'INSTANT.
»
Parce que je ne suis pas censé voler
uniquement le philosophe
qu’il ne faut pas nommer
- il faut que je multiplie les vols,
et ce faisant,
je choisis des influences
qui me créent moi-même
- plus je vole,
plus j’enrichis mon identité.
Le deuxième secret de la créativité,
c’est donc de commencer sans se connaître
- parce que l’identité de l’artiste
naît au sein même
du processus artistique.
Il faut se débarrasser
du syndrome de l’imposteur,
parce que tout n’est qu’imposture
dans ce monde !
Des centaines de personnes
ont plagié Arrr…
Des centaines de personnes ont plagié
le philosophe qu’il ne faut pas nommer
en prétendant avoir
leur propre originalité !
Austin Kleon invite l’artiste en mal de
créativité
à s’approprier
la devise de la Silicon Valley :
« Fake it
‘til you make it.
»
Le débutant doit prétendre être
ce qu’il n’est pas encore,
ou accomplir
ce qu’il n’a pas encore accompli.
Là,
je dois dire
que je suis assez sceptique :
déjà,
ça me pose un problème moral,
mais je vois surtout deux effets pervers
à cette philosophie :
si on est trop à l’aise avec l’imposture,
on risque de finir par s’en contenter,
et de ne rien produire du tout ;
et le second effet pervers,
c’est qu’on peut être pris,
sans le vouloir,
dans un espèce d’effet Ponzi
du mensonge
- il faut mentir à nouveau
pour conforter le mensonge initial,
et puis ah zut
il en faut ensuite un troisième,
puis un quatrième
- jusqu’à bâtir entièrement
une oeuvre,
et une réputation
sur le mensonge.
Donc à mon humble avis,
la culture de l’imposture,
c’est risqué,
comme le montrent d’ailleurs
certains scandales de la Silicon Valley.
Personnellement,
je préfère la philosophie de la créativité
de Jack London :
pour réussir en tant qu’artiste,
mieux vaut se sacrifier
soi-même au travail,
plutôt que ses principes.
MAIS
Austin Kleon regagne mon adhésion
quand il précise ce qui distingue
l’inspiration mimétique
du plagiat :
l’artiste qui copie son modèle
ne se contente pas de le copier,
il s’approprie son style
et sa vision du monde
dans le but de le dépasser
- c’est-à-dire que l’imitation est saine,
dans la créativité,
quand elle débouche sur l’émulation.
Par exemple,
le basketteur Kobe Bryant
a avoué avoir entièrement puisé
son répertoire technique
chez ses prédécesseurs,
MAIS
il a adapté les mouvements
à sa morphologie
et il les a retravaillés
pour essayer de les améliorer.
C’est donc en dépassant ses modèles
avec leur propres styles
qu’il est devenu Kobe Bryant,
un des meilleurs joueurs
de l’histoire de la NBA.
Ainsi, c’est en volant
que l’artiste apprend,
puis devient lui-même.
« Personne ne naît
avec un style ou une voix,
écrit Austin Kleon.
Nous ne sortons pas du ventre de notre mère
en sachant qui nous sommes.
Au début,
nous apprenons
en faisant semblant d'être nos héros.
Nous apprenons en copiant.
»
Alors qu’il m’a fallu des heures
pour finalement décider
de plagier
le philosophe qu’il ne faut pas nommer,
Austin Kleon,
lui,
raconte qu’il a écrit
la suite du film Jurassic Park
comme ça,
en revenant de la séance
- et il était enfant !
D’où est-ce qu’il a tiré
autant de créativité ?
Est-ce qu’il se droguait déjà
comme les startuppers
de la Silicon Valley ?
Ça,
on ne saura pas
- son explication à lui,
c’est tout simplement
qu’il a écrit
l’histoire qu’il voulait lire.
Il a simplement obéi
à sa pulsion créative.
Et d’après lui,
ce principe de créativité est valable
pour tout :
« Dessinez ce que vous voulez voir,
démarrez l'entreprise que vous voulez diriger,
jouez la musique que vous voulez entendre,
écrivez les livres que vous voulez lire,
construisez les produits que vous voulez utiliser
– faites le travail que vous voulez voir
fait.
»
Alors,
Austin Kleon n’explique pas
pourquoi il s’agit d’un bon principe pour
réussir,
mais c’est probablement que notre propre
désir
de lire de que l’on s’apprête à écrire,
ce désir est peut-être révélateur
de l’existence d’une base potentielle
de lecteurs.
L’expert en productivité de la Silicon
Valley
Tim Ferriss
dit que si on résout un problème
pour soi-même,
la solution pourrait probablement servir
à beaucoup plus de monde.
Austin Kleon préfère que l’écriture
reste un processus manuel,
parce que d’après lui,
les mouvements du corps
favorisent l’inspiration.
Après,
il garde un bureau digital,
et il passe successivement
de son bureau manuel
à son bureau digital.
S'il se méfie de l’ordinateur,
c’est parce qu'il trouve
qu’il nuit à sa créativité
en le coupant de son environnement.
Il souligne aussi
que la facilité à éditer le contenu
avec un ordinateur
favorise le perfectionnisme.
Mais là,
j’ai du mal à le suivre :
faciliter l’édition du contenu,
c’est faciliter son amélioration,
donc c’est plutôt
en faveur du progrès de l’art,
non ?
Il aurait mieux fait de parler
de l’effet des animaux de compagnie
sur la créativité.
Austin Kleon prend ses distances
avec le premier précepte de la productivité
:
la concentration,
ou le focus en anglais.
On dit généralement
qu’il faut concentrer toutes ses forces
sur un projet unique
- et on comprend bien pourquoi
avec ce petit schéma -
MAIS pour Austin Kleon,
il ne faut pas s’interdire des projets annexes,
il ne faut pas abandonner ses passions,
parce que la magie de la créativité
opère en réalité
dans l’interaction
entre le projet principal
et ce qu’il y a autour.
Lui, par exemple,
prétend avoir boosté sa créativité
en reprenant la musique.
Là, encore une fois,
je ne suis pas convaincu :
je peux comprendre le principe,
mais je ne crois pas
que ça soit un super conseil
à notre époque où
la dispersion est en train de devenir
une vraie maladie.
Et puis dans l’absolu,
il reste la question du temps :
si on empile les projets,
on va avancer trop lentement
dans chacun d’entre eux.
Austin Kleon prône également
ce qu’il appelle la « procrastination productive
»,
c’est-à-dire perdre volontairement du temps
- par exemple,
en repassant,
en faisant la vaisselle,
en marchant,
ou en se perdant dans ses pensées -
pour accélérer
la fermentation des idées.
Là,
je suis plutôt d’accord avec lui,
mais je trouve
qu’il ne s’agit pas véritablement
de procrastination,
mais tout simplement
de la nécessité de faire des pauses.
Bref,
je suis assez sceptique
en ce qui concerne ce cinquième secret.
En revanche,
j’adhère totalement au suivant.
Ouf !
Vous êtes encore là !
J’ai de la chance si vous êtes encore là,
parce que l’attention du public
est très difficile à gagner
- les gens n’ont pas de temps
à consacrer
à l’oeuvre de l’artiste.
Du coup,
le retour à la réalité peut être difficile
après les fantasmes du départ ;
MAIS l’absence de public
est aussi une opportunité :
comme presque personne
ne va juger le travail du débutant,
il a la possibilité,
et il a même intérêt
à essayer différentes choses.
De toute façon,
le processus créatif suit généralement
les mêmes phases :
on commence le projet
en pensant que c’est une idée géniale
;
on arrive à un état quasi dépressif ;
puis on finit par produire quelque chose
de moins bien que prévu,
mais de pas si mal quand même.
Aujourd’hui,
il faut toujours travailler aussi dur,
mais une chose a changé :
grâce à internet,
il est beaucoup plus facile
de diffuser son travail.
Austin Kleon conseille donc
de développer une relation avec son public
- de lui raconter sa vie,
de lui dévoiler les coulisses des projets,
et plus généralement
de se familiariser avec les nouvelles solutions
qui permettent de partager le travail artistique.
Après,
internet accroit aussi la concurrence ;
donc le débutant n’a pas le choix :
il doit miser
sur la QUALITÉ
pour sortir du lot.
Le sixième conseil est donc :
faites du bon travail,
puis partagez-le.
Austin Kleon vit à Austin,
Texas
- non,
c’est pas une blague,
Austin vit à Austin.
Donc c’est là
qu’il est la plupart du temps.
Et pourtant,
il estime que sa ville
compte pour moins de dix pour cent
de son inspiration
- les quatre-vingt dix
autres pour cents
viennent d’ailleurs.
Du monde entier,
en fait,
parce que ses modèles
sont éparpillés un peu partout
- grâce à internet,
il voyage mentalement,
et il customise son bureau
pour cultiver cette forme d’inspiration.
De temps en temps,
il fait aussi de vrais voyages
- où il se déplace matériellement.
Les voyages ont un effet bénéfique sur la
créativité
parce qu’ils sortent l’artiste
de sa zone de confort géographique
- et ce faisant,
ils le poussent à se confronter au nouveau,
à remettre en cause
sa vision du monde.
En particulier,
ils lui permettent de rencontrer
des artistes plus talentueux que lui,
qui le tirent vers le haut
- et ça c’est crucial
d’après Austin Kleon,
parce que
SANS ÉMULATION
on ne progresse pas.
« Si jamais il s’avère
que vous êtes la personne
la plus talentueuse de la pièce,
vous devez en trouver une autre ».
Mais ce n’est pas une raison
pour être malveillant
avec les artistes moins talentueux.
Déjà que le monde est petit ;
mais à l’heure d’internet, c’est pire
:
tout se sait,
et les traces sont presque indélébiles.
Un tweet incontrôlé,
un commentaire impulsif,
et une réputation
peut être entachée à jamais.
Voici donc la règle d’Austin Kleon :
rester bienveillant
et ignorer ses ennemis.
Le secret,
à cet égard,
c’est de rediriger ses pulsions négatives
vers la créativité.
De travailler dur,
encore plus dur
avec l’énergie des pulsions négatives,
sans attendre passivement
une confirmation extérieure.
« Soyez à l'aise avec le fait d'être mal
compris,
dénigré
ou ignoré
– l'astuce consiste à être trop occupé
à faire votre travail
pour vous en soucier.
»
En revanche,
si vous recevez des compliments,
vous avez intérêt à essayer
de prolonger l’énergie,
le surcroît de motivation
qu’ils vous procurent.
Par exemple,
Austin Kleon met de côté
tous les avis positifs qu’il reçoit
pour en retrouver l’effet dynamogène
quand il en aura besoin.
Quant aux avis négatifs,
il fait comme s’ils n’existaient pas.
Moi je ne suis pas cette règle ;
donc si vous avez envie de me critiquer
dans les commentaires,
sentez-vous libre de le faire
- je laisserai votre commentaire
et je répondrai du mieux que je peux
- si ça peut me rendre plus créatif !
Bon,
ce neuvième secret
n’en est pas vraiment un.
Pour réussir en tant qu'artiste il faut…
travailler !
Ah d’accord !
Alors,
Austin Kleon ne le présente pas comme ça
- il dit « être ennuyeux »,
mais si le quotidien de l’artiste
est entre guillemets ennuyeux,
c’est parce qu’on ne peut pas produire
une oeuvre
dans la piscine d’une villa
ou en descendant les pistes
sur un snowboard
- sinon il faut prendre des nègres
comme les hommes politiques,
mais je ne pense pas
que les hommes politiques
revendiquent le statut d’artiste
(même s’ils peuvent l’être
à leur manière).
Ce neuvième secret,
c’est plus précisément
qu’il faut organiser son quotidien
et formater son environnement
pour favoriser la régularité du travail.
J’aime beaucoup la citation de Flaubert
que donne Austin Kleon :
« Soyez régulier et ordonné dans votre
vie
comme un bourgeois,
ainsi vous pourrez être emporté et original
dans votre œuvre.
»
C’est une évidence,
mais on n’écrit pas Guerre et Paix
en boîte de nuit.
Le génie romantique drogué en permanence
et qui meurt au sommet de son art,
c’est un fantasme,
parce que la créativité consomme trop d’énergie
pour que l’artiste la gâche par ailleurs.
C’est pour ça que le débutant
a intérêt à être économe
comme un petit bourgeois,
afin que d'éventuels soucis financiers
ne le détournent pas de son oeuvre.
Austin Kleon lui conseille,
comme Jack London,
de se trouver un job alimentaire.
C’est la garantie de sa liberté artistique
- sauf s’il écrit des poèmes contre son
patron,
mais il peut faire tout le reste ;
c’est aussi la garantie d’une vie sociale
;
ça peut être une source d’inspiration
et enfin,
ça lui impose une routine.
Paradoxalement,
un job alimentaire peut même
le rendre plus régulier dans le travail,
parce que ça le contraint
à tirer le maximum du temps restant.
Ça,
c’est la fameuse loi de Parkinson :
si vous avez quatre heures
pour écrire mille mots,
vous allez avoir tendance
à produire ce quota
pile en quatre heures.
Et le second avantage de la régularité
auquel fait référence Austin Kleon,
c’est l’effet cumulé :
« La constitution d'une œuvre
ou la construction d'une carrière
est en grande partie liée à la lente accumulation
de petits bouts d'efforts au fil du temps.
Écrire une page chaque jour ne semble pas
beaucoup,
mais faites-le pendant
trois cent soixante-cinq jours
et vous avez assez pour remplir un roman.
»
Petit conseil pratique d’Austin Kleon :
pour supporter l’accumulation de ces petits
bouts d’efforts,
munissez-vous d’un calendrier dédié
et d’un journal de bord.
Bon,
c’est pas très sexy tout ça !
On n’est pas dans Californication !
Austin Kleon reconnaît d'ailleurs
que l’ennui du quotidien de l’écrivain
risque aussi de contaminer
sa vie de couple.
Ça c’est un vrai secret :
la créativité artistique augmente
PAR SOUSTRACTION.
Plus le processus créatif est simple,
plus il sera efficace ;
moins l’artiste se disperse,
meilleurs seront les résultats.
Ça,
c’est quand même en contradiction
avec le secret numéro cinq,
vous vous souvenez,
cultiver une certaine dispersion.
Austin Kleon parle surtout
de l’importance de la soustraction
à propos de l’information :
comme nous vivons dans une société
où l’information est excessivement abondante,
ce qui a de la valeur,
désormais,
c’est le TRAITEMENT
de l’information,
à commencer par la sélection.
Mais ce secret de la soustraction
s’applique de manière beaucoup plus générale
:
ça s’appelle la via negativa.
Cette idée évoquée notamment par Nassim
Taleb
dans son essai Antifragile
signifie que
tout processus se perfectionne
par la simplification.
C’est peut-être celui-ci,
le secret crucial de la liste d’Austin Kleon
:
vous voulez être créatif ?
Faites simple
pour faire mieux ;
restez dans les limites
de la simplicité.
Les artistes qui réussissent
savent ce que leur créativité
doit aux contraintes :
c’est paradoxalement du combat
contre leurs propres limites
qu’est née leur œuvre.
Voici donc
les dix secrets de la créativité
des artistes,
et en particulier des écrivains qui réussissent
:
copier les autres artistes ;
commencer sans se connaître ;
écrire ce que l’on veut lire ;
utiliser ses mains,
plutôt que de tout faire à l’ordinateur
;
cultiver une certaine dispersion ;
diffuser un travail de qualité ;
voyager,
en esprit ou en vrai ;
rester bienveillant ;
assumer d'être ennuyeux ;
et enfin,
simplifier le processus créatif.
Alors,
vous l’avez compris,
je ne suis pas d’accord avec tout.
Je ne suis pas un artiste
- du coup encore moins
un qui a réussi
mais je suis sceptique à l'égard
du "fake it til you make it"
la devise de la Silicon Valley ;
de la préférence
pour les processus manuels,
et de l’encouragement
aux projets annexes.
En revanche,
je suis convaincu
par les trois secrets
qui sont à mes yeux
les plus importants :
ce qu’Austin Kleon
appelle « voler » les autres artistes,
même s’il a expliqué
la nuance avec le plagiat ;
le fait d’écrire ce qu’on voudrait lire,
un principe que j’ai déjà lu ou entendu
par ailleurs ;
et enfin,
je l’ai déjà dit,
la via negativa,
soit la nécessité de simplifier
le processus créatif.
Mais bon,
le principe fondamental du livre,
c’est bien « voler comme un artiste ».
L’artiste qui a réussi est un plagiaire
curieux,
méthodique,
et ambitieux ;
le débutant en quête d’authenticité,
lui,
attendra longtemps.
« Ceux qui ne veulent rien imiter
ne produisent rien.
»
Merci d’avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu’au
bout !
Si vous voulez décupler ma créativité,
donnez un pouce bleu à la vidéo,
et puis abonnez-vous à la chaîne
si vous aimez la vulgarisation
de la pensée ;
et enfin,
laissez un petit commentaire,
et je vous promets de rester bienveillant,
comme le recommande Austin Kleon,
mais sans vous ignorer.
Je vous permets aussi
de télécharger
mes notes de lectures,
et si vous voulez lire
ma synthèse écrite détaillée
de Voler comme un artiste
qui est sur le blog,
ou si vous souhaitez lire l'essai directement,
tous les liens sont dans la description.
Je suis Romain,
je suis avec mon fidèle Haristote
- pas le philosophe,
le chihuahua -
et sous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Vous n’avez pas besoin
de plagier qui que ce soit
pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée,
SANS vous prendre la tête.